the jurogan experience the problem is
those preppers
they're just a little too paranoid and
they [ __ ] it up for everybody else
you know what i'm saying that's why you
can't buy bullets right now you can't
buy bullets right now i need people need
to know this
people out there that don't own guns
first of all gun ownership
radically increased in 2020 correct
and gun purchases went up and then
bullet purchases went up and and they're
hoarding them all i mean they can't even
make them fast enough i mean you're
talking to a guy who got shot in 92.
did you get shot [ __ ] carjacking oh
yeah i was a police officer show me your
arm came in uh
back here on my shoulder and came out
down here you were a police officer back
then
dude i was a police officer firefighter
and paramedic before i was old enough to
drink
that's crazy a little bit of an
overachiever wow
that's great how did you get involved in
that how old were you when you joined
the force
uh i went into the police academy in 18.
yeah you could be a cop at 18. uh i got
my certification when i was 19.
that is crazy when were you on the force
pulling people over
uh late 19. that is so
crazy yeah i spent some time in a little
suburb of dallas called alvarado and
then i ended up at the tarrant county
constable's office
and then i ended up getting hired on by
a city up there at carpel
and uh spent uh they put me through the
fire academy and uh
uh medic school and so that's what i did
until i was like
27 ish 26.
so how old were you when you get shot
92 so i guess i was 22. so you were 22
and you were stopping a carjacking no
i was actually had been out that night
with a buddy of mine and uh he got lucky
went home with some chick
so i did not i was going uh through the
water burger drive-thru and
a couple of guys came up and got me from
behind
wow yeah what kind of car 65 mustang uh
fastback gold on gold
it's a nice car nice car yeah the
problem is you had good taste even back
then
yeah yeah i was always flipping and
buying cars all through uh school as a
matter of fact
i graduated high school i started my
driver's license when i was 16 with a
250.76 impala
and uh finished high school you know two
and a half years later two years later
with a bandit trans am i got four speed
t topped red on black with uh the big
gold bird
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience